un bel espoir sans doute pour les
enfants atteints de mucoviscidose ils
sont plusieurs milliers en france la
greffe de poumons réalisé il ya quelques
jours à paris ouvrent des perspectives
disons immense une équipe de l'hôpital
broussais réussi l'incroyable
c'est-à-dire greffer sur une malade un
poumon coupée en deux et voilà deux
nouveaux organes en état de marche
premières explications en images avec
romuald de beaune en première mondiale
en matière de transplantation pulmonaire
qui vient de réussir à l'hôpital
broussais de paris le succès de cette
équipe de médecins français du service
de chirurgie cardio vasculaire du
professeur carpentier depuis plus d'un
an
l'une de leurs patientes attendait un
don d'organes extrêmement rare deux
poumons d'un même donneur pour remplacer
les siens rongé par une fibrose avec des
complications asthmatique et
infectieuses pour cette malade de 40 ans
alité depuis plusieurs mois le moindre
geste lui causer des douleurs
insupportables
alors le 15 mai une greffe a été tentée
à partir d'un seul poumon adultes deux
poumons plus petit mais en état de
marche ont été fabriquées durée de
l'opération
10 heures comme vous voyez le poumon
comprend deux parties qui sont pas
totalement séparées et chirurgicalement
il va falloir il ya ce qu'on appelle
c'est sûr c'est à dire une annonce de
séparation qu'il faut terminer
chirurgicalement
lorsqu'on arrive aux pellicules c'est à
dire à l'ensemble artères 20 bronches
qui est public
il va falloir divisé l'ensemble des
seules choses pour faire deux pellicules
pour avoir deux bouts cette nouvelle
technique du docteur croit-il fait
naître un énorme espoir pour les enfants
atteints de mucoviscidose
il ya souvent un poumon qui nous ont
proposé je crois que c'est là
certainement une excellente issue pour
transporter les enfants avec un seul
poumon je pense qu'on pourra
transplanter les enfants qui nécessitent
une double transplantation pulmonaire
la malade transplantés elle il ya trois
semaines a recommencé à marcher sa
sortie de l'hôpital broussais est prévue
lundi prochain